so today we're talking about the
possible free-to-play battlefield that's
coming
soonish far off in the future and
speaking of far off in the future we're
also talking about nintendo reconfirming
that its next console will be ready
before
one
2100.
i'm devonte and this is gamespot news
speaking during ea's latest earnings
call ceo andrew wilson said one of ea's
goals is to expand the modalities of
play and give players more options for
how they want to consume content
wilson said it quote probably makes
sense for the battlefield series to have
a free to play component someday in the
future ea isn't doing that just yet
because the first job is to provide a
quote reinvention of the series and it
believes battlefield 2042 is just that
the next phase of battlefield's ongoing
expansion will be to launch the
free-to-play battlefield mobile after
that ea might look to release another
free-to-play battlefield game presumably
for console and pc ea has experimented
with free-to-play battlefield games in
the past like battlefield heroes and
battlefield play for free though they
didn't last too long
and now let's move on to some nintendo
news as part of a q a with investors on
friday nintendo shared a slide related
to its quote future outlook and this
included mention of an integrated
hardware software next gaming system
that will arrive by the end of 2099
analyst david gibson who attended the
meeting and translated from japanese
said nintendo management explained that
the switch is only in the middle phase
of his life cycle as such whatever
console might come next is likely still
a long time off nintendo is currently
having discussions about the concept and
launch timing for the new machine
and now let's check in on new world
because it's been a rough week for the
game's entirely player driven economy
all forms of wealth trading were
disabled for an entire day recently due
to exploits in which players were
duplicating money and items the game's
latest update 1.0.5
has patched these exploits while also
fixing an issue revolving around gold
duplication on territory projects that
was introduced following the disabling
of in-game trading players under level
10 or those whose account is less than
72 hours old won't be able to trade with
other players or transfer money players
also won't be able to use the game's
trading post until completing the
introduction to trading post quest
gold rewards from some early quests have
been reduced and moved to later in the
main quest line to prevent new accounts
from easily making gold
now to some unfortunate news now as the
video card manufacturer evga has
confirmed one of its trucks carrying rtx
30 cards was overtaken by thieves
recently in route to san francisco from
a southern california distribution
center posting on its forum evga said
the heist took place on october 29th
thieves apparently succeeded in stopping
the truck and making off with an
unspecified number of geforce rtx 30
series cards
it's not immediately clear how many
units were on the truck but it's not
hard to imagine this being a very
substantial heist specific details about
how the heists went down are unavailable
evga also reminded people that it is a
crime under u.s federal law to buy or
receive stolen property and this would
also include these cards as such the
company advised that people should check
the serial number of any evga cards they
might come into ownership of and run
them against the my products page if the
card can be registered then it wasn't
stolen anyone with information to share
should do so at stop rtx 30 theft
evga.com
so do you want a free to play
battlefield are you excited for
nintendo's next console what graphics
card are you rocking in your pc right
now let me know all the answers to those
questions in the comments down below and
i will see you
when i see you
[Music]
you